Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my
existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep,
and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you,
my beloved divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to
your most holy will so intimately that I may never swerve from carrying out what I know to be your
good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will, that you never perceive
even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the
angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the
holy spirit and infuse in me true light, so that I may understand the truths and the good that are
in these writings and prayers. Amen. So we want to begin this evening with October the 26th, 1926.
And we start with Louisa doing rounds of redemption. And Jesus showing her the deeper levels of
understanding that are in the gospels. One of the things that is noticeable about Louisa doing rounds
is that they are real meditations that she does. Sometimes I have seen lists of rounds in which
people just simply name mountains, hills, lakes, this kind of stuff. And it's not a meditation,
it's not really going into the thing. If you were making just a very, very quick list of things,
how could the Lord actually give you a deeper insight? So Louisa's going to show us the way here
in some of these messages here. She says, as I continued to unite myself with the acts of Jesus,
that means to fuse herself in what Jesus did in redemption, my always lovable Jesus came and told
me, my daughter, see how all the acts that I did in redeeming man, and even the miracles I performed
in my public life, had no other purpose but to call back the kingdom of the supreme fiat
into the midst of creatures. So the first thing he does is gives the motive behind everything.
And in the act of doing them, I asked my celestial father to make the divine will known and to restore
it into the midst of the human generations. So first of all, you have the motivation,
and then you have him actually requesting this in all of his acts. Now watch this.
If I gave sight to the blind, my first act was to put to flight the darkness of the human will,
which is the primary cause of the blindness of the soul and of the body. Now there you have an
insight that nobody else can give you. What is the primary cause of the blindness of our souls
and bodies? He says it's the darkness of the human will. So that the light of my will might
illumine the souls of many blind, that spiritually blind, that they might obtain the sight to look
at my will. Now notice that spiritual blindness is the basic problem that he says is in us so that
they might obtain the sight to look at my will in order to love it. And their bodies might also be
exempt from losing their sight. So notice that as we go deeper into the divine will that our health
recovers as well, because our external bodies reflect what's actually going on inside of us,
and that has been proven by scientists and medical people that 98% of all illness that isn't an
accident actually has a spiritual source. And it's very important for us to look at spiritual sources
of things. The second example he gives is if I gave hearing to the deaf, first I asked my father
that they might acquire the hearing, we would say the ability to hear the voice and the knowledge
and the prejudice of the divine will. Now notice that hearing is much deeper than the ears,
because if we're to hear the voice of the divine will, if we are to grasp the knowledge of the
divine will, if we're to somehow grasp the prejudice of the divine will, that interior hearing,
just as sight was interior as well, so that the divine will might enter into their hearts as the way
in order to dominate them, we would say as the root in order to dominate them,
and there might be no more death that is spiritually deaf people in the world,
either in the soul or in the body. Now that doesn't mean that a person at this moment
is blind or deaf, that it is because of sin, Jesus himself dealt with that in the gospel.
Do you remember when he was asked, was it himself or his parents who sinned that this child was born
deaf mute and Jesus said neither of them? He's talking about the human race and that this problem
is in the human race and the human race needs to recover so that none of these terrible tragedies
need to happen. Third example he gives is also in the dead that I resurrected, I asked that souls
might rise again to my eternal will, even those who are putrified, that supports Lazarus,
John chapter 11, and made more than cadavers by the human will, so he's saying that even the
tragedy of death and the putrefaction of the body is nothing to the putrefaction of our souls
through the human will. And he said, and when I took robes to drive the profaners out of the
temple, it was the human will that I was driving out, of course they were all operating the human
will in their buying and their selling and their shouting and all the rest of it, so that my will
might enter, reigning and dominating, and they might be truly rich in their souls and no longer
subject to natural poverty. Wonderful insight there that I hope the human race actually discovers
at some point and that is that if our souls are rich in God, there will be no natural poverty
because there will be the correct sharing one to the other and there will be no grabbing of land
and no grabbing of money and no grabbing of anything so that every human being will have their needs.
Notice that the answer to the human race is not COP 26, it's the human will surrendering to God.
And Jesus said, when I entered into Jerusalem in my triumphant entry in the midst of the crowds,
surrounded by honor and glory, it was the triumph of my will that I established amidst the peoples.
So everything is the divine will. Okay, so in the next paragraph he tells us that the divine will
is the origin of every good, hence you go back over the examples he has just given to you here,
the human will was surrendered to the divine will, none of the tragedies that Jesus had to
actually deal with would happen. So we have to understand that the source of all good is the
divine will, the origin of everything. There was no act that I did while being on the earth
in which I did not place my will as the prime act to be established once again,
that was the ultimate purpose of everything. And because that was the thing I most cared about,
if I didn't do so, he said everything that I did and worked and suffered, he said it wouldn't
have accomplished anything. So if in everything I worked and I suffered, I did not have the kingdom
of the supreme will as the prime act to be restored in the midst of creatures. My coming on earth would
have only been a half good. It wouldn't have been complete because the complete one is to restore
everything back to its origin and to have paradise regained. And paradise can only be regained
if the human will surrenders to the divine. So in fact, since my will is the origin of every good
and the only purpose of creation and redemption, because he is the creator, he can tell you what
the purpose of creation and redemption was, it is therefore the ultimate fulfillment of all our works.
There's a very, very important statement there. And if you have your own book in front of you,
you need to really mark that without the divine will, our most beautiful works remain within a
frame and without completion. Within a frame is very bad translation. It means very limited,
closed in, there's no fulfillment. Okay, because the divine will alone is the crown
of our works and the seal that our work is complete. Therefore, for the honor and glory of the very
work of redemption, the divine will was to have as its prime act the purpose of the kingdom of my
will. So in the next paragraph, we have intercession to restore the divine will on earth. This is going
to a beautiful place. So after this, Louisa said, I was beginning my round in the divine will and
going into the terrestrial Eden in which Adam had done the first act of withdrawal of his will from
the divine. Now here she's giving us real headline as to how to pray. I said to my sweet Jesus, my love,
I want to annihilate my will in yours. Now this is her response to give reparation for the fall
of Adam. Okay, I want to annihilate my will in yours that it may never have life so that your will
may have life in everything and forever. I want to do this in order to repair for the first act
that Adam did and return to your supreme volition all the glory as if Adam had never withdrawn from
it. Now notice she's only interested in God. I want you to notice her motivation. All she wants to do
is first of all make reparation to the divine will for the act that Adam did and she wants to restore
God's glory which Adam denied him by falling. So this is pure love for God. There's nothing else
in it. There's nothing in it for herself and there's nothing in it for any other human being.
This is total love for God. This is your Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10. So oh how I wish to give back to him
this is Adam. Now watch this for love of neighbor, a neighbor you never met. Oh how I wish to give
back to Adam the honor that he lost because he did his own will and rejected yours. And I intend to
do this for as many times as all creatures have done their own will which is the cause of all evils
which we have just read about in the first two paragraphs by rejecting your divine will. This is
the purest love for God and neighbor you could ever imagine. There's literally nothing in it for
herself. So the divine will is the origin and the fountain of all goods. Therefore I pray you
she said to the Lord that the kingdom of the supreme fiat will come soon so that everyone from
Adam onwards up to the last creatures may receive the honor and glory which they lost
and your will may receive triumph and glory and fulfillment. It's the most wonderful example of
perfect love of God and neighbor that I know of. I think it's absolutely fantastic. All she wants
is that God will receive all the glory and that everybody will recover and that everybody will be
able to come back into the divine will and therefore everybody will be able to receive what God wants
for them. It's not the most perfect way to pray. Very often we fall back into what I call
itsy bitsys, little tiny little things and we're not thinking on this absolutely universal scale.
I don't know if you are impressed but the Lord was very impressed and in the next paragraph he
actually brings Adam to talk to Louisa. I don't think there's another example of this in human
history. So she said while I was saying this my highest good Jesus was moved naturally so would I
be and he was touched and making my first father Adam present to me he allowed Adam to speak to
Louisa and with great emphasis of love he said this is Adam speaking. Blessed daughter finally my
Lord God after so many centuries has delivered to the light of day the one who was to even think
about nobody else has given us even a slightest thought to this the one who is even to think about
giving me back the armor and glory that I lost by doing my will. How I feel my happiness redoubled
until now no one has ever thought of giving me back the armor which I lost nobody thinks of Adam
let alone restoring what he lost. Therefore he said I thank God profoundly for having delivered
you to the light and I thank you the daughter dearest to me for taking on the commitment
of giving back to God the glory as if his will had never been offended by me and giving back to me
the great honor that the kingdom of the supreme fear will be established once again in the midst
of the human generations. So here she is blessed and thanked by the very one who caused the problem
it's very moving thing here and so Adam says it is right that I give you my place the place that
had been destined to me now what was destined to him was to be the first born in the divine will
and he said it's right that Louisa should have that place and not him as the first creature that
came out of the hands of the Creator okay so here Louisa shows us how to pray and how to know what
is the center reality of prayer which is God and that love has got to go out absolutely pure
to God and absolutely pure to others you're looking for literally nothing for yourself
if you're still looking for something for yourself you haven't made a lot of progress in the divine
will so in the next paragraph we're told that the whole of heaven even awaits our acts and why would
that be you're going to see after this my beloved Jesus clasping me to himself in other words he
gives her a big hug told Louisa my daughter not only Adam but the whole of heaven awaits your
acts in my will in order to receive the honor which their human will has taken away from them
of course all the saints in heaven were operating in the human will because they didn't know about
the revelation about the divine will and so there's greater honor and glory that they can receive
which we can help them with it's absolutely amazing to think that you can help the saints
you must know that I have placed more grace in you than I placed in Adam so that my will might
possess you dominate you and triumph and yours will feel honored never to have life and to give
the place to my will in Adam I did not place my humanity as his help and strength and as court
age of my will because I didn't have it then so it depends on what generation you actually live in
but I have placed it in you to provide you with all the necessary helps so that your will might
remain at its place that means surrendered to God and mine my reign and together with you might
follow your rounds in my eternal volition in order to establish my kingdom so Louisa has helped
that was not available for Adam because we live after the incarnation and so we have all of Jesus's
acts and all of Mary's acts to help us and we who are living a century after Louisa after some of
these writings we have the help of Louisa's acts as well so on hearing this Louisa was surprised
and she said my Jesus what he's saying it seems to me that you want to tempt me and make fun of me
how is it possible that you have placed more grace in me than in Adam because we think of Adam as
absolutely perfect which he was and Jesus said certainly my daughter I had to make it so so that
your will might be sustained by another higher humanity now why is that it's because Louisa was
born like you and me with original sin it is a totally different case with her blessed mother
totally different case altogether so she was born with original sin and therefore like you and me
she needed the help of this divine humanity in order to help us he said so that you wouldn't stagger
and that you would remain firm you'd remain steady in the divine will because it's one thing to get
really interested in the divine will and then fall away he says no for you to stay therefore I'm not
making fun of you and I'm telling you this so that you will correspond to me and you'll be attentive
so I think that's a really lovely message to have so let's come to October the 29th 1926 and in the
very first paragraph we have the answer in my opinion to the earth worship that's going on today
people today in their desire to heal the earth from the climate change that we have think that by
sort of worshipping mother earth that they're going to achieve it that's not so watch what Jesus
says it's beautiful. Louisa said I was continuing my round in all of creation in order to follow
each act of the supreme will in each created thing so her meditation is going on all day
it's absolutely amazing and my always lovable Jesus came out from within my interior to accompany me
through the whole space of the vault of heavens now watch what he's going to say to her now the
vault of the heavens is what we would call the place where you meet all the galaxies it's not
the celestial fatherland and as we reached each created thing Jesus gave starts of joy and love
and then pausing he told me my daughter I created the heavens and I centralized my love for man
underlying in the heavens that's like a father saying that he has made something very wonderful
for his children and his love for his children is manifested in this thing that he has made for them
so I centralized my love for man in the heavens and in order to give him greater delight I
started them with stars he created massive beauty for us to delight him watch this now this is the
answer and to me I have a VIP on this line I did not love the heavens I loved man in the heavens
because it was for him that I created them there's your answer to all this earth worship today and
for this I want to give you Colossians 1 verses 15 to 20 I want to give you John chapter 1 verses
3 and 18 and I want to give you Hebrews chapter 1 verses 3 and 6 now if Jesus loved us in the heavens
and we start contemplating the heavens in our rounds what are we loving you know the answer
because it's been given to you many times okay I did not love the heavens he said I loved man
in the heavens and for him I created them how strong and great was my love in extending this
asior vault above the head of man adorned with the most refulgent star of like a pavilion for him
such that neither kings nor emperors could have the likes but I didn't content myself with
centralizing my love for man in the heavens which were to serve him as pure delight so
contemplating the heavens at night is what he wants because that's when you see this pure delight
wanting to delight in love with him that is with us I started to create the sun now what he always
comes to the sun we're going to have the sun and we're going to have the sea a couple of times okay
I wanted to create the sun so we're now at the solar system we're out of all the galaxies in the
heavens and down to the solar system centralizing so much love for man in the sun I love man in the
sun not the sun it's very important not the sun and therefore I placed in it the love of necessity
because the sun was necessary to the earth having to serve the plants as well as the well being of
man there is the love of light which was to illuminate him there is the love of fire which was to warm
him there were all the effects which this sphere produces which are innumerable a continuous miracle
placed in the vault of the heavens which descends with its light for the good of all
not with anything to do with god is for the good of all I centralized so many specialities of love
towards man in the sun for as many goods and effects that it produces so let's just make a little
list for a second the sun does so much for us it gives us light it gives us heat it gives us warmth
it actually is incredibly important for our mood it gives life and all the rest of it okay god is
light god is life god is fire god is our nourishment god is the source of our growth
so he has given us a symbol of himself and when we look back at that symbol we're to see him
not to hug the sun so let's come to the second paragraph the rounds that we do have to be
rounds of love because god has loved us infinitely in everything he has created and made for our use
and we are to love him infinitely back through the divine will or to give the response that's
actually due to him or if the creature at least paid attention to my love which the sun brings to her
how happy i would feel and repaid for the great love i placed in this divine relater of mine
that's a divine revealer as i've just said god is light god is love god is fire and so on
and the sun is the bearer of my love and my light while my supreme will
operation constituting itself the life of each created thing in order to give itself as life
to the human generations now notice how he gets around this he has been talking about what he has
put into the the sun for us and then he tells us you know that he intends that this light and this
divine will is absolutely to be the center of our being and he has done this out of pure love for
us okay so that the divine will is actually life in the human generations and through them he said
love making its way in my eternal fiat would centralize itself in the love of man
so we give the perfect response of the human race when we give back love and thanksgiving
and glory and praise in the divine will so in each created thing in the wind in the sea in the
little flower in the little bird that sings in everything i centralize my love therefore in doing
rounds we can't just make a list and say the words the bees for da da da da da da da da da
we can't just do that louis is actually going into this and really looking at the presence of god
that's there so that she can actually glorify god for the miracle he has done in that little
bee or that little bird or that little flower or whatever it is in other words she's actually
entering into the mystery but in order to hear and to comprehend and to receive my language of love
man was supposed to love me otherwise all creation would remain as mute and lifeless for him
how many how many on this earth have creation mute and lifeless now we're not the first ones
who felt that we had to praise god for everything that he had made if you go to the last three
sam's in the salter sam 1 4 8 sam 1 4 9 and sam 1 50 you will find that the salter ends in a
peon of praise giving glory and praise and thanksgiving to god now i don't know if you've studied
the salter but the whole 150 sam's goes from the very beginning it goes from unbelief and
sinfulness and everything through repentance and through growing and through falling back and
repenting again and growing again and entering into union with god and ends up in what i call
the standing ovation to god which is sam 150 so the people of the mosaic covenant
did know that they had to respond to god in glory and praise and they did a wonderful job in the
sam's with it so we now come to the creation of man and the one who is identified in these
writings as the ungrateful one the one you can give everything to i won't even thank you for it so
jesus said now after i created everything in other words i made this incredible palace
which is the universe i formed the nature of man let's say that in english that we use
i made human beings and i made them with my own creative hands this is terribly important
there's your answer to Darwinism we have not evolved we have not evolved and what is being said here
you will find in jesus chapter one verses 26 to 30 he said i formed human beings with my own
creative hands that's exactly what the book of jesus says and as i formed the bones extended
the nerves formed the heart and so i centralized my love in other words everything was an expression
of his love and after i clothed it in with flesh forming as though the most beautiful statue because
when you read jesus one 26 and jesus chapter two it actually reads as if he's making a statue
after forming as though most beautiful statue which no other art person could ever made he said i
looked at him and i loved him so much that i'm able to contain my love it overflowed
and breathing upon him i infused life into him now that is ruach adhanai or uach
adonai the breath of god the spirit of god and therefore this life that is infused into us is
not just physical life it's spiritual life notice we go into the plural then we were not content
the blessed trinity was not content in an excessive love the most holy trinity wanted to
endow man giving him intellect memory and will therefore making him superior to all other creatures
according to his capacity as a creature we enriched him with all the particles of our divine being
now would you underline that in about three colors i for those of you who are Irish i always say
green white and gold we endowed human beings with all the particles of our divine being
all you've got to do is meditate on the miracles that are actually you the miracle of how your eyes
work the miracle of how your ears work how your heart works how the blood works and so on and so
on he says examine it and scientists have found the signature of god in the dna
mukkon go down that route here and go to stay with the text just want you to know that
the whole of the divinity was intent on loving man and on pouring itself upon him so if you love
somebody you pour out your whole being upon this person okay from the very first instance of his
life he felt all the strength of our love because as you know adam was created adult
so he felt all the strength of our love and from the depth of his heart he expressed with his own
voice love for his creator this was the first time that anything in creation spoke back to god
and the first thing he said was i love you oh how happy we felt in hearing our work
the statue made by us speaking we are the speaking creation and we have to speak on behalf of all
the others who don't have voice we have to praise god and thank god and glorify god
for all the others who don't have voice and he spoke with perfect love why do you speak with
perfect love because he had the divine will in him and therefore he had divine love in him
so it's only the divine will that can enable you to give god love that is divine so love is our
perfect response to god want to give you john 59 for that as the father has loved me jesus said
so i love you so you must love one another and that is with divine love i want to give you
john 13 34 and 35 we are to love as jesus loved and one Corinthians 14 one you must want love
more than anything else love is the essence of the whole thing god is love that's his essence
and when we love we are allowing god to express himself in us and through us
and therefore you can preach very eloquently to other people without actually preaching at them
i love that statement of Saint Francis of Assisi where he told his friars to go out and preach the
gospel and speak if necessary but he got them to serve others he got them to reach out to the poor
he got love to come out of them and divine love expressed through them the people then would ask
the question where is this coming from so this love that came out of adam had not been contaminated
by his human will and therefore his love was perfect because he possessed the fullness of our
love we can only do that in the divine will until then of all the things created by us
not one thing had said to us that it loved us now hearing that man loved us our joy our
contentment was so great that as the fulfillment of our feast we constituted him king of the universe
in other words he was superior to all other creatures because he could love god
with this divine love and we constituted him the most beautiful jewel of our creator hands
how beautiful man was in the first times that is before the fall he was our reflection
it looked like us two Corinthians 3 18 and these reflections gave him so much beauty as to enrapture
our love and to render him perfect in all of his acts now in this part of the paragraph we're going
to be talking about what paradise is and paradise is harmony in the divine order
so all his acts was perfect and to correct the next sentence which is not English the glory he gave
to his creator was perfect and the adoration love and works that he gave were perfect as well
perfect because in the divine will his voice was so harmonious as to resound in the whole of creation
because he possessed the divine harmony notice the divine harmony he was in the divine order
and harmony is the central aspect of beauty that everything is in its right place he possessed
the divine harmony and the harmony of that fiat which had given him life everything was order
in him this is where we have to go back to because our will brought him the order of his creator
in other words what we call paradise is actually the divine will operating fully and completely in
the human being it's actually nothing to do with what's outside of you it's internal the kingdom
of god is within you that's Luke 17 21 the kingdom of god is within you paradise is within it doesn't
really matter where it was located upon the earth because if the whole earth comes back to the lord
in the new era paradise will be everywhere everything was ordered in him because our will
brought him the order of his creator rendered him happy and it made him grow in our lightness
and according to our words let us make man in our image and likeness in other words adam was
everything god wanted him to be each one of his acts now that's whether he walked or sat down
or ate or slept or anything each one of his acts done in the unity of the light of the supreme fiat
was a tint of divine beauty now notice each act in the divine will makes us more and more like god
another little touch of the divine brush upon us each word of his was one more harmonious note
that resounded everything was love in him in everything he sang the praises of our glory of our power
of our infinite wisdom and everything heavens sun and earth everything brought him the joys the
happiness and the love of the one who created him now this sounds awfully like sam eight let me read
a few verses of sam eight for you and i'm only going to start at verse three when i consider your
heavens the work of your hands the moon and the stars that you have set in place what is man
that you are even mindful of him the son of man that you would even care for him yet you've made
him a little less than a god you've crowned him with glory and honor you've made him ruler over
all the works of your hands and you've put everything under his feet how great is your name
or lord our god through all the earth i only read a tiny little bit of it but it reflects what's
being said actually here now the next short paragraph is an example that he gives and while i'm reading
this i go to say to you think of your own children jesus said that's what i'm like if you could make
a stature the way you like the best and then you poured all of yourself into it giving it all the
vital humors and with the power of your love you gave life to it you gave birth to a child how much
would you not love it because that child is another you and how much would you not want it to love you
what would your jealousy of love not be so that the whole of this would remain at your disposal
and such that you would not tolerate even one heartbeat that would not be done for you
and in your statue you would look at yourself as the whole point you see another yourself
and therefore at every little thing not done for you you would feel a tearing inside of your very
self now so i asked you to apply it to your children in so far as you could because he's
talking about a statue here and he's saying the statue that he's talking about of course is humanity
and he's just giving us the logic behind it that if you've made something that is totally reflecting
yourself it really hurts when it goes off in a different direction now he's saying that because
he wants to say in the final paragraph that's what i'm like and he's going to describe that human
beings today are living off God's love and refusing to acknowledge him so that's a bit like children
at home you've given life to them you've done everything for them there's nothing else you can do
and they are ungrateful and they don't cooperate and you know you know how you feel that's what he's
talking about so we're talking about ungrateful children here and the ungrateful children is
the human race everything that the creature doesn't do for me he said are tearings that i feel
more so since the earth that sustains her is mine the sun that illuminates and warms her is mine
the water she drinks the food she takes they're all mine everything's mine she lives at my expense
and while i give her everything she my beautiful statue is not for me what must my sorrow be then
and the affront and the offense that this statue gives to me think about it yourself my daughter
now you must know that my will alone can give me back my statue that's a very important statement
first of all he describes the sickness it's actually in the human race and the only way that the human
race can actually finally be restored is through the divine will only my will can give me back the
statue beautiful as i made it because my will is the preserver of all our works and the bearer of all
our reflections in such a way that the soul lives from our reflections which if she loves will
administer to her the perfection of our love if she works will administer to her the perfection
of our works in some everything she does is perfect in her and this perfection gives her so many
tints of divine different beauties as to enamour the maker who formed her this is why i love so much
that the supreme fiat be known and form its kingdom in the midst of the human generations to establish
the order between the creator and the creature in other words he's got to bring us right back
to square one to start all over again because we're literally living off him ungrateful and not giving
him back love not giving him back anything that he has given to us and so to bring back this order
and this harmony to restore paradise on the earth the one thing that is required is that the human
will would surrender to the divine so we have to establish the order between the creator and the
creature and to place our goods in common with her okay our will alone has this power without it
there cannot be much good that's very kind of him there can't be any good nor can our statue return
to us that this is the VIP statement at the end the human race can't return to us as beautiful as
it came out of our creative hands in other words god doesn't want a mess coming back to him so let's
go to november the first 1926 and we're still at contemplating creation and here we get it in my
opinion a good lesson on how to contemplate god in his creation because that's the question i might
have asked after the first message of tonight so louisa said i was doing my usual round in the
whole of creation in order to be able to love and glorify as the divine fiat itself loves and
glorifies now look at the motivation okay so i'm doing this round in order to be able to love and
glorify god so we need to ask ourselves why we do rounds what are we doing in doing rounds
the pie is terribly important but when i was doing this i thought to myself my sweet
Jesus makes me go around through the whole of creation as though one to reach his will in all
its acts two to keep him company three to give him and i love you of mine a thank you and i adore you
of mine and four to ask that his kingdom may come soon now notice the four things that are required
but i do not know all that the divine volition does in each creation things i would like to know
what she said so that i can do my acts in a more wonderful way so jesus going to respond to this
in a very wonderful way so while i was thinking of this my beloved jesus all goodness came out from
within my interior and told me it is right that the little daughter of my will know
the one from whom her origin came in other words if we do the rounds correctly if we really
contemplate god and his creation really contemplate jesus in his redemption really contemplate what
the holy spirit has done in sanctification then we will come to know god we will actually come to
know him and if we're only just you know stringing off names and i've seen strings of names you know
i love you in the trees and they're this and they're this and they're this and this and this and this
that never did anything for me so he says he must come to know him in his works
that's like saying that a great architect has put up a massive building and we go and admire the
wonderful work and we examine so look how he did he do that that's incredible i'd never have thought
of putting it that shape or whatever it is you're going around you're actually contemplating the
person's work or you go to one of the great paintings the famous paintings and you you just
massively admire what this person was able to communicate using colors it's incredible that's
what we're doing in the rounds so we have to be contemplatives people really entering into god's
work so he said it is right so you must know he said that my eternal fiat not only fills the whole
of creation and is the life very creation thing what keeps all of our qualities spread out in
the whole of creation now that's the bit he's after that if we were doing the rounds correctly
we would actually be getting to know him an awful lot better in fact creation was to serve
as the terrestrial paradise as we know from genesis one and two for the human family
and therefore it was to be the echo of the beauties and the happiness of heaven
so what was in heaven was to be seen on the earth now this is very clear when you study the
book of exodus for example when Moses was given a revelation of how to worship god he was told
to make a copy of what he had seen in heaven on the earth and so the tabernacle that he actually
built was a copy of what he had seen in the heavens that's terribly important so what was
done on the earth is meant to be an echo of the beatitudes and the happiness that's in heaven
if it did not contain the joys and the contentment of the celestial fatherland
how could it form the happiness of a terrestrial one if it didn't have this more so since there's
only one will the divine will it's only one whether it's in heaven or on earth whether it's operating
out in the universe or whether it's operating inside of me or operating in the church or operating
wherever there's only one will so both that which beatified heaven and that which wanted to make
the earth happy so whether the divine will is operating in the heavenly sphere or whether it's
operating under it's the same divine will it will have exactly the same results which is paradise
heaven so it's the same will okay there's only one will now if you want to know what my will does
in the heavens now the heavens is not the celestial fatherland the heavens are what we call the area
where the galaxies are in that asia that's the blue sky we say space and the extraordinary thing is
we say space and it is occupied by hundreds of billions of galaxies all of whom have hundreds of
billions of stars in them and yet we still call it space because it looks empty to us in these
writings it's always called the asia because it looks blue to us in that age or which appears
always firm and stretched out above the heads of all there's not one point in which the heavens
cannot be seen both at night and in the daytime they remain always in their place so he tells us
that all the time that anything that is in the divine will has stability in it and it's not all
over the place they stay in their place so our will keeps our eternity our firmness that never
changes spread out so we're looking at God's eternity we're looking at God's immensity we're
looking at his stability the firmness and it's spread out in everything he has made it remains
always in its perfect balance now that you're coming to harmony again everything's in balance
nothing is out of place nor does it ever change because of any circumstance and while it loves
and glorifies our eternity our unshakeable being it makes the earth happy and says to man look take
the heavens as a model which are always stretched out above your head be always firm in good just as I
am always stretched out from here in order to protect you so that you too like a second heaven
populated with stars which to your eyes seem so bound to the heavens that it can be said that
the stars are daughters of the heavens so that you too will be firm and good and the heaven of your
soul will be populated by stars like the births from the daughters of yours that's the divine
births which are our acts so he's saying that we contemplate God in the glory of the heavens
and that we're to learn from that to be stable and to remain in our place and to allow God to
actually let us be an echo of what is actually in heaven so in doing your rounds in creation
Jesus said when you arrive at the heavens you too united with our will love and glorify our
eternity what are you doing loving and glorifying God's eternity our unshakeable being that never
changes and you pray that it renders souls firm in good and that they may be the reflection of the
heavens and may enjoy the happiness brought by a good that is never interrupted that's what he says
we're supposed to be doing when we are contemplating now he's going to give an example of the sun again
in the next paragraph and then he's going to give us an example of the sea so the sun is the symbol
of God's light and it is the celestial carrier of his divine majesty so we're going to be contemplating
God as light God is the source of life then continuing your round in the space of creation you arrive
at the sun so we're now at the solar system a sphere which is closer to the earth than the heavens
in other words we've come out of that area where all the galaxies are and much closer to ourselves
in order to bring to creatures the source of terrestrial happiness and the similes of the
beatitudes and the flavors of the happiness of the celestial fatherland do you want to know then
what my will does in the sun it glorifies our endless light one john one five god is light
our innumerable flavors now why does he say that because the sun gives innumerable flavors
to plants on the earth it loves and glorifies the infinity of our sweetness
the indescribable tints of our beauties because those tints of those beauties are put on all the
plants of the earth and with its heat it echoes our immense love so light and love god is light god
is love god is love one john four seven oh how the sun sings our praises and loves and glorifies
our divine being just as our divinity unveiled beatifies the whole celestial fatherland would
act ever new in the same way the sun fateful echo of its creator is the celestial bearer
of the supreme majesty in other words a revealer of god veiled by its light
in which my will dominates and reigns and it brings terrestrial happiness to the earth
to prove that all you need to do is wake up with the the rain coming down in torrents and the place
absolutely dark and then the clouds push away the sun comes out and everybody's totally happy
it brings its light and it brings its heat it brings sweetness and flavors almost innumerable
to plants herbs and fruits it brings color and fragrance to the flowers and so many different
tints of beauty as to delight and embellish all nature oh how the sun rather my will in the sun
through plants fruits and flowers offers true terrestrial happiness notice that you're being
shown how to do the meditation and if they don't enjoy it fully it's because they have moved away
from that will which reigns in the sun and the human will placing itself against the divine
breaks the happiness and my will veiled in the light of the sun while loving and singing
the praises of our divine qualities from the height where this sphere says to man in everything
you do be always light now there you have Matthew 5 4 and verse 16 you are the light of the world
the city on that mountain so in everything you do be always light just as I am so that the light
may convert you completely into heat which of course is love so you may become as one single
flame of love for your creation and as Saint John of the Cross wrote one of his most famous works
called the living flame of love look at me Jesus said by being always light and heat I possess
sweetness now notice this is the opposite of the bitterness of the earth when people are out of
sync with God so much so that I communicated to plants and from the plants to you you too if you
are always light and heat you will possess divine sweetness now when you read the lives of the saints
you often come across this in the text that these people were noted for a great sweetness of manner
whereas worldly people who are in rebellion against gods will you have anger and resentment
and bitterness and all that darkness stuff so if you are always light and heat you will possess
the divine sweetness and you will have no more vile and angers in your heart notice the vile and
angers comes from the distorted human will you will possess the flavors and the different tints
of the beauties of the supreme being you will be a sun like me more so since god made the sun that
is me for you and you were made for him because it is right for you to be more a sun than I was
like as if the sun is actually talking to you there and saying that you should be a sun also
being light and heat to other people so in the next paragraph Jesus tells us that he is in a veiled
manner in the sun but he would like to be unveiled among us very important see my daughter how many
things you have to do united with my will in that sphere of the sun you have to sing the praises
love and glorify our light our love our infinite sweetness our innumerable flavors and our
incomprehensible beauty and you have to pray for creatures all the divine qualities which the
sun contains so that in finding the divine qualities in their midst my will may come to reign unveiled
with its full triumph in the midst of the human generations so we go from veiled to unveiled now
the second example he gives us is the sea and this is a symbol of divine purity power and strength
so notice if you're contemplating the sea this is what you're contemplating these aspects of god
now my daughter let us descend into the lower part of the earth let us go into the sea
and its immense masses of crystal clear waters are piled up when i'm reading this i feel uncomfortable
because we've destroyed the sea now and it's full of junk this sea is a symbol of divine purity
these waters are always moving they never stop they are without voice and yet they murmur
they are without life and yet they are so strong as to form waves so high that they can
overwhelm and shatter ships and people and things and then descend into their shore having knocked
down things which they have invested in other words tsunamis and then they land peacefully as if
they had done nothing continuing their usual murmuring oh how my will in the sea sings the praises
loves and glorifies our power our strengths our eternal motion that never stops and if our justice
forms in its roaring waves such as to knock down cities and peoples like the peaceful sea after
the storm our peace is never disturbed and my will veiled by the waters of the sea says to man
be pure like these crystal clear waters if you want to be pure move always towards heaven
otherwise you would putify just as these waters so pure would putify if they did not move
let the murmuring of your prayer be continuous and that's a beautiful beautiful expression
how would you ever have thought of going from the murmuring of the waters to the murmuring of prayer
let the murmuring of your prayer be continuous if you want to be strong and powerful like me
if you want to knock down the strongest enemies and your own rebellious will
which prevents me from unveiling myself to you okay and going out of this sea to come and rain
in you and extend in you the peaceful sea of my grace is it possible that you want to remain
below the sea that glorifies me so much do you see that these contemplations would absolutely elevate
you completely so to sing the praises love and glorify our purity our power our strength our
justice united to my will that awaits you in the sea as its own daughter as well as our eternal
motion towards creatures in order to do good to them and the continuous murmuring of our love
through all the created things which while at murmur's love once the continuous requital of
murmuring and continuous love of creatures so here you have this continuous movement of love
coming from him to us and from us to him he wants that continuous movement all the time
and pray my will to give them the divine qualities exercises in the sea so that it may come and rain
in the midst of those who keep it rejected in the whole of creation so if you want to know what my
will does in all the creation just go around in it in other words contemplate meditate on it
and my fiat finding its daughter in all created things will unveil itself the Lord will reveal
to you he will invest you with knowledge and understanding and he will tell you what does towards
the divine majesty and the call and the lessons it wants to give to souls i've done that a little
bit quickly because i'm over my time okay but the main thing that he's saying is that in the rounds
we actually contemplate god in his creation and so i think it's very important not to make lists